ya know I want to come back also to what
you were saying about the predictive
power of IQ and conscientiousness which
I don't dispute and I'm also not what
are these people who suffers under the
delusion that these things are totally
open quote socially determined close
quotes I mean I understand and believe
that they have high heritability and
identifiable genetic sources in that
variability and so on but you know the
standard old joke used to be you can
tell because you know more about
personality psychology that I do the
standard old junk used to be that
everything's 50% heritable that done
pretty much anything that you could
measure as a trait that has any
stability within the lifetime also turns
out to have a heritability somewhere
near point 5 but there's the other point
5 of you know some people have low IQs
because they were exposed to too much
led Memphis II you know I believe that
conscientiousness can probably be what I
believe you suggested earlier that we
know something about this already about
developmental determinants of shifts in
conscientiousness and so you know we
have to caution ourselves against
talking about these individual
difference factors as if they are
beautiful attributes of individuals that
are going to undermine any sort of
progressive improvement of of status for
people are gonna create bad byproducts
of attempts to produce social justice
it's just gonna you know you're gonna
leave your your dumb bug country and
just people out there being parasites or
something well you know there there is
of course decent evidence that there are
socio-cultural effects on IQ I mean the
Flynn effect which is named after the
man who described the the phenomena
indicates that the average IQ has been
increasing quite substantially over the
last hundred years and the reason for
that no one knows for sure but one of
the putative reasons for that is that
we've lifted the bottom out of
catastrophe
so there aren't people whose IQs are
stunted by my exposure to zero
information during critical
developmental periods and who didn't get
enough to eat yes I was gonna say severe
malnutrition everybody zero information
yeah exactly so we've we've wiped out in
many ways we've wiped out the worst
effects of privation and that's
increasingly true as well on on the
worldwide scale world stage you know
there's about a hundred and fifty
thousand people a day right now being
lifted out of absolute poverty by UN
standards the fastest improvement in the
history of the world by a huge margin
and also about three hundred thousand
people a day being hooked up to the
electrical grid so we are making some
progress
removing the absolute privation problem
which is an oath reveal problem the
problem with most of the attempts to
raise IQ is that they don't change the
variance in IQ they tend to raise the
average IQ across the population and
that leaves the inequality I I Q
inequality problem basically untouched
so there have been studies trying to
estimate how much socio-economic
pressure let's say you have to place on
an individual to raise their IQ lowering
it's easy right because make them
something worse is always easier than
making something better well if I
remember correctly if you take an
identical twin who's adopted out at
Birth in order to produce a 15-point
increase in IQ compared to the other
twin which is a one standard deviation
increase and about the same as the
average difference between a university
student it is in an average state
college and an average high school
student you have to move the one twin
from the 5th percentile of socioeconomic
status to the 95th percentile so you
need about a three standard deviation
improvement in socio-economic conditions
to produce a one standard deviation
improvement in IQ so it looks like it
can be done but it's but it's expensive
you know and I say I see what you're
saying I'm kind of surprised actually
I've been given you know we just
mentioned malnutrition as one possible
source of low I
q what possible developmental source I'm
kind of surprised that to the degree
that the flit effect might be due to
things like a reduction of the number of
people exposed to severe malnutrition
that it wouldn't have also
simultaneously truncated the variance a
little bit that seems like they said
well it has true let me restate that it
has truncated it has truncated the
variance although the data on that isn't
clear isn't as clear so but but I do
believe that it's a reasonable inference
to make that the variances been
truncated it's also hidden to some
degree because the IQ tests are always
renormalize
so it makes it difficult to look
retrospectively and see what's happened
to the variance so but the other problem
too is that you know you get these
stories now and then about these
companies that come out with claims that
their brain exercises can improve IQ and
the literature on that is damn dismal I
can tell you it's that the Holy Grail is
to produce cognitive exercises that
produce a legitimate impact on fluid
intelligence and like there has been a
lot of work done on that and the answer
so far is that it doesn't work so what
let me get what about the video gaming I
mean I know there has been this
suggestion that playing video games
actually improves at least some aspects
of intelligent video games might improve
spatial intelligence but but here's the
problem and and I think this is this is
a critical problem perhaps an insoluble
one or at least no one solved it is that
what you get is that if you if you
exercise yourself substantially on a
given game you can radically accelerate
your performance in the game so you can
get much better at those specific skills
sure but you don't get generalization
across cognitive sets which is what
you're really hoping for because I
thought I thought that was the claim
from some of these they have shown some
increases in spatial IQ but there's not
very many studies and I would say
they're far over balanced by the other
side of the search equation which
continually says and I've looked at this
because I'm really interested in the
improvement of IQ I mean that's that's
the Holy Grail in some sense and that
and and the the deal
the overwhelming preponderance of that
suggest that you don't get
generalization outside the narrow domain
now why that is and even this it's even
worse a because you might say well
imagine that you could take five
different domains of intelligence still
associated tightly with with G and you
have people practice routines in all
five dimensions maybe you'd get
generalization under those circumstances
and the the the results of the research
attempting that indicate that no as soon
as you move away from those specific
practice instances you don't get
generalization